hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 4 video that you
know big big firestorm episode but the
end of the episode should have made you
flip your table like get out of your
chair and scream it was so much fun
that's the sign of a good show like when
you get really excited about the big
twist in the episode you get to see a
new firestorm be created firestorm v2
but then it surprises you at the very
end in a way that just makes you crap
your pants so I'm going to do is my top
5 WTF moments then I'll explain the
comic book characters and do Easter eggs
all all the stuff we will do all the
things so just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet and
don't forget there is a new round of the
reverse flash ring giveaway I'm just
giving away a new running every week all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so first things first meet Jax
Jackson your new firestorm
what they've done is they've taken a lot
of classic Ronnie Raymond from the
comics the witty banter that he had with
the Martin Stein character and combined
it with Jason Rush and used a different
name like I said I think they're just
trying to avoid any confusion because
they already cast jason rusch on the
show but that character that actor isn't
someone they want to use with legends of
tomorrow but they want classic firestorm
they want a lot of that fun witty banter
so Jax is just an amalgam of a lot of
those things they kind of did that with
season one of the flash - they they
combined a lot of Wally West's run a lot
of the humor of the Wally West run in
the comics with things names characters
from the Barry Allen era so the flash TV
show just in general is an amalgam of a
lot of different eras of the flash in
the comics one of the issues they bumped
up against when they when they were
dealing with the Ronnie Raymond
firestorm is that in the comics Ronnie
is kind of like a dumb jock character
but they turned Robbie and Mel's
character into something of an engineer
so you lose some of the energy that the
classic Ronnie had in the comics so so
Jax is kind of a course correction in
that sense Franz is a great actor he was
then attacked the block with John boyega
who's blowing it up in the Star Wars
universe so it's gonna be great it's
gonna be a lot of fun having him on the
show but primarily he's going to be a
legends of tomorrow character definitely
expect to see him again in an episode
before the mid-season finale the
mid-season finale on the flash is going
to be the Vandal Savage episode when
they kind of tee up the need for the
legends of tomorrow team up until then
they're just gonna use episodes to
explain who all these characters are
like the next big one will probably end
up meeting will be Hawkgirl and Hawkman
and so everybody high-five Jax welcome
to the team the big villain they gave
him to defeat was talk amok Henry Hewitt
talk amok he's a classic firestorm
villain from the comics notice that
Cisco didn't object when Caitlyn gave
him the name Cisco's been pretty nice
this season about losing other
characters name villains Trent tries to
step on his toes too much though on the
number four though
iris versus her mother so that I
actually really like what they did with
irises character this week this is
generally this is gonna be irises big
thing this season is fixing her family
just like Barry's mission in season one
was fixing his family
Kalin had this really good speech with
Jax Jackson it was it was a really great
Daniel Pennebaker moment where she was
talking about possibilities right in
front of you being a part of something
bigger you could totally reapportionment
I receive storyline take the chance on
her mother for the opportunity to be
part of something bigger you know making
her family bigger literally and
figuratively the way she ended things
didn't sound very hopeful so there's
still like a couple hurdles that iris
has to jump over emotionally before
she's gonna be ready to let this all end
but I feel like giving her the Wally
West reveal was one of the best things
they did for her in the episode using
irises abilities as a good reporter like
she's actually a pretty good reporter to
find out about wally west which it
sounds like joe doesn't know about yet
so moving on to number three meet wally
west mystery child of joe west and
irises mother this might have been a
little bit confusing because iris is
like this baby was born eight months
after you left central city who's the
father i feel like it would have been a
very different story if iris had said
ten months after she left central city
then you definitely would have been like
okay okay this is definitely somebody
else's child but I do think she and Joe
did the deed before she bailed and took
off so Wally West is Joe's son this is
gonna be like a big smack in the face
for Joe but of course I think that Joe
is gonna take some of his own advice and
accept Wally into the family he has a
habit of adopting rescue puppies I mean
just look at Barry he's like the
ultimate rescue puppy so of course he's
gonna invite Wally West in at a certain
point you know maybe not right away
maybe not right on the spot but it's
definitely gonna happen that that's just
the good person that Joe is and if it
wasn't clear when irises mother said
that she had disease and they only gave
her a year but they're kind of saying is
is that she's probably gonna die at the
end of this season like she'll live to
the end of this shows year iris was
totally mature about the whole thing but
if you really want to know what she
thinks of her mother just think about
the way she speaks to her my father told
me you said you were sick she does she
doesn't refer to her as your mother she
doesn't say hey mom
so I think eventually you know like once
they heal their family she'll start
calling her mom that's when you'll know
she'll have fully accepted her mom in
but I think that's gonna take most of
the season to do on the number two
though Harrison wells is back he's
walking and making everyone poop their
pants
don't tell Barry nobody tell Barry about
him that was so great when Joe was like
you cannot tell Barry and Pat patty is
just like I don't I don't I don't do the
lion so well not not so much that's just
the show telling you that patty is like
a really good person they really want
you to trust her because she's so bad at
lying if you were really good liar then
it probably harder to trust her but I
think the device that Harrison stole
from mercury labs was the device that he
used to say Barry like the giant taser
weapon and this is real deal King shark
they did him just because they're not
gonna be doing him all the time it was
meant to be a special thing
the Harrison wells of Earth too isn't an
evil character I mean he's basically
gonna like fill in for Martin Stein
whenever legends of tomorrow picks up
he'll be like the mature adviser on the
team he's just gonna be a big douche bag
before the particle accelerator
explosion he was a big hero of Barry's
so now Barry is meeting that hero the
actual Harrison wells he's not a Oh Bart
Thorne in disguise he's not the
reverse-flash so Barry's gonna have to
deal with meeting his hero and then
finding out that his hero is a complete
but Tom Cavanagh is a series regular
he's gonna be here for most of the
season you know no idea is what's gonna
happen to him at the end hopefully he
won't die because then we'll have to
meet earth-three Harrison wells is like
Tom Cavanagh is trying to challenge
Tatiana maslany on orphan black for the
number of characters played by the same
actor in the same show but just to
address Barry and Patti I know it was
pretty obvious in the episode that their
seating a relationship between those two
there is like a date night episode
coming no idea if they're gonna turn
patty into heart pursuit at any any time
she might just be regular patty for the
rest of the season the way she is now
the way Diggle doesn't have superpowers
but he's kind of a superhero she's she's
kind of like a Diggle type character
just a normal badass on their own I have
been seeing some awesome patty zoom
theories I do like the idea of that you
know just like the fun they could have
with playing really good patty against
really evil patty but again I think zoom
himself is a male
character but speaking of zoom on to my
number one WTF table flipping amazing
moment man shark giant freaking shark on
the flash this was so awesome just in
case you never read it there was a flash
season zero comic book it was a tie-in
with season 1 of the show I don't know
if they're still doing it or not but
they introduced this shark character in
that comic book during that story it
gets recruited for the Suicide Squad so
my understanding is that it was supposed
to be king shark but this version of the
character is from earth-2 so there might
be some some slight changes I was
actually really excited for patty to
save Barry as the flash she doesn't know
that Barry's the flash by the way but
the Harrison wells reveal at the end was
even better just like one WTF rolling
into another WTF we go from wally west
oh my god to king shark holy to
Harrison wells
WTF so you guys let me know which WTF
reveal was your favorite in the episode
I mean was it seeing the new firestorm
we kind of saw him coming that wasn't as
big of a surprise was it wally west or
was a giant freakin shark i think this
episode is definitely gonna be one of
the most fun ones from season two to
re-watch but I am expecting some even
better stuff to be coming in the second
half of the season like we know we have
a big Grodd episode coming the other
really fun Easter egg that I took I
totally loved it was kind of a small
moment but at the beginning when they
turned the reverse flashes wheelchair
into a super cane for Martin Stein to
stabilize him super wheelchair becomes
super cane and that's kind of the end of
the reverse flashes technology they they
used it to build the new containment
device the producer said they've already
gotten rid of Gideon like there's no
Gideon at STAR Labs anymore they can't
they can't ask that questions about the
future the funny thing is is at the end
of this week's episode I made like the
same like oh my god face as I did at the
end of Walking Dead on Sunday night for
completely different reasons
totally different types of WTF so what's
gonna happen next is I'm still catching
up with Supergirl in a couple other
videos be sure to subscribe to get
everything
what while you guys wait for that I just
posted my Gotham video you can click
here to watch that metahumans coming to
Gotham two different metahumans then
from the metahumans on
so I don't I don't think they can share
characters and you guys can click here
for my WTF Walking Dead video if you
haven't seen that yet thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tomorrow